hall au trio de tête quelle joie d'être
avec vous c'est un bonheur de pouvoir
partager ce cette aventure et pour
commencer de vous dire quelques mots de
notre projet de ce projet que nous
allons porter ensemble ce projet qui a
une histoire parce que j'ai trop entendu
au début de cette campagne que la ligne
des républicains n'étaient pas claires
qu'elle n'était pas assez transparente
et bien c'est faux nous sommes les
premiers sous l'impulsion laurent
wauquiez à avoir fixé les piliers de
notre engagement européen c'était à
menton il ya plusieurs mois
vous avez voté cette ligne que nous nous
sommes fixés et elle a été la base d'un
travail très intense et très exigeant
qui a été menée par toute une équipe
autour de guillaume larrivé que je
voudrais saluer ici abonnés l'homme et
qui nous permet d'aboutir à ce projet
que nous allons porter tout au long de
cette campagne un projet tu l'as dit
gert-jan un projet concret un projet
complet un projet cohérent et surtout un
projet qui est à la hauteur du rendez
vous historique qui se joue pour
l'europe
à l'occasion de ce rendez vous de
l'élection européenne car oui c'est vrai
nous croyons à l'europe et nous croyons
que notre avenir passe par l'europe mais
nous savons aussi cher joseph daul c'est
une joie de le dire devant vous nous
savons aussi que l'europe que nous
voulons
elle ne ressemble pas à ce qu'elle est
parfois devenu au cours des dernières
années sous l'effet de certains abandons
sous l'effet de certains échecs qui
créent aujourd'hui la défiance que nous
voyons partout surgir avec agnès avec
arnaud nous sommes sur le terrain depuis
plus d'un mois maintenant et tous les
jours nous entendons hier nous étions
chez toi cher damien abad
tous les jours nous entendons la même
chose l'europe nous déçoit l'europe nous
manque
l'europe nous fait défaut dans la
mondialisation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
avec tous ces grands déséquilibres avec
tous ces grands défis
l'europe donne trop souvent le sentiment
de nous fragile
et au lieu de nous renforcer alors dans
cette situation on voudrait nous faire
croire que le choix serait entre
l'impuissance du déni et l'inefficacité
de la colère nous nous voulons prendre
au sérieux cette colère nous voulons
l'entendre et non pas l'insulter nous ne
croyons pas que nos adversaires soient
ceux qui doutent de l'europe nous
pensons que nos adversaires ce sont tous
nos échecs toutes nos impuissances tout
ce qui ne fonctionne pas en europe et
que nous ne parviendrons à vaincre ses
défiance que si nous parvenons à re
faire de l'europe un auxiliaire efficace
de nos libertés que si nous parvenons à
faire de l'europe un appui et non une
fragilité et c'est tout le sens de ce
projet que nous allons partager ensemble
ce projet vous l'avez avec vous il vous
a été distribué et ce projet nous allons
maintenant vous le présentez très
brièvement avec arnaud et agnès vous le
retrouverez de façon beaucoup plus
complète dans ce petit livret et surtout
vous allez l'entendre et l'entendre
encore et vous allez en entendre parler
et vous allez en parler pendant les
semaines qui viennent
ce projet c'est le projet des
républicains qui parle d'une seule voix
pour défendre cette europe que nous
voulons avec hervé morin avec les
centristes avec cette famille rassemblée
qui dira à quel point nous voulons de
l'europe mais à quel point pour sauver
l'europe
nous savons qu'il faut la changer je
passe la parole à agnès
merci mon cher françois xavier je
voudrais tout d'abord vous dire
évidemment que c'est une immense fierté
pour moi de m'exprimer devant le conseil
national pour la première fois et je
voudrais également en tant que président
de la fédération les républicains de
paris dira à tous les adhérents à tous
les militants qui sont ici présents
toute ma reconnaissance pour votre
fidélité et votre engagement sans faille
derrière les républicains sans vous rien
ne serait possible et ce ne sont pas des
mots je le mesure chaque jour en tant
que président de la fédération de paris
alors nous allons faire un manuel macron
la pire mauvaise surprise de l'année
2009-2010 après mac du quinquennat et
même du quinquennat parce que je peux
vous dire que nous allons gagner
nous allons gagner parce que son jeu
totalement cynique d'essayer d'en fermer
le débat européen dans un débat binaire
entre d'un côté les progressistes le
camp du bien et d'un autre les
populistes le camp du mal les méchants
est un jeu qui est non seulement
réducteur et extrêmement dangereux mais
que les français ont parfaitement bien
compris et qu'ils sont tiendront au mois
de mai 2019
[Applaudissements]
et je peux vous dire que en effet et
françois-xavier l'a dit nous sommes au
quotidien sur le terrain et nous sentons
bien que la droite elle est bien là la
droite est bien vivante et quand je vois
je veux vous voici présent si nombreux
aujourd'hui ça démontre encore une fois
que nous sommes là et que la droite
aujourd'hui renouveler et accompagné
aussi d'expérience et c'est très
important parce que moi je ne crois pas
au jeunisme je crois surtout à la
solidité de l'expérience et quand je
vous vois si nombreux jeux ludiques en
effet ce que nous ressentons jour après
jour sur le terrain que cette broche
cette droite est bien présente et
qu'elle n'est ni incarné par emmanuel
macron ni marine le pen que nous devons
croire en nous et alors je voudrais vous
dire donc qu'il y a au coeur du projet
le sujet de notre civilisation
européenne et c'est pour moi un des
enjeux de cette échéance électorale et
je vous le dis en tant que vice
présidente de la région ile de france en
charge de la culture et du patrimoine la
culture est un puissant moteur de
cohésion sociale la culture c'est ce qui
nous rassemble tous dans notre histoire
et de nos valeurs communes et tout
particulièrement dans une société
fracturée comme la nôtre est marquée par
des discours obscurantiste et l'europe
c'est aussi une histoire une culture une
civilisation et notre responsabilité à
nous chez les républicains parce que
nous sommes les seuls à en parler c'est
de protéger nos cultures nationales et
de protéger nos civilisations
européennes
c'est extrêmement important parce que la
france c'est aussi notre nos racines nos
terroirs notre histoire notre langue
qu'il est absolument fondamental de
préserver parce que l'enjeu c'est aussi
la survie de nos nations et la survie de
notre civilisation en tant que
civilisation unique face à des super
puissances comme la chine
les états unis et donc croyait bien que
j'aurais extrêmement à coeur de défendre
et de protéger cette civilisation
européenne qui fait toute notre histoire
et qui était un enjeu fondamental en
tout cas dans cette échéance européenne
nous n'aurons cesse de préserver nos
racines notre culture et notre histoire
est donc dans notre projet vous avez
nous avons notamment une proposition qui
vise à inscrire en fait dans les traités
européens
les origines jd au chrétiennes de notre
civilisation
mais aussi mais aussi notre héritage
gréco romains et des lumières de cette
europe parce que vous le savez en tant
que vice-présidente de la région culture
et patrimoine au sens étymologique du
terme
le mot patrimoine signifie les biens de
famille signifie notre bien commun
signifie notre héritage que nous devons
transmettre et le mot transmission n'est
pas un gros mot nous devons l'assumer
nous devons courageusement dire que face
à la montée de l'islamisme
oui nous devons protéger nos cultures
nationales et notre civilisation
européenne
ce n'est pas jean leonetti en effet qui
me démentira et nous voulons même
transmettre cette civilisation
européenne à nos jeunes puisque nous
allons leur proposer en fait la
possibilité dans le cadre d'un semestre
d'aller prendre des cours d'histoire de
l'europe à travers les pays européens et
donc c'est une possibilité pour eux
aussi justement de d'accueillir de
recevoir ce message de notre histoire
européenne
ça c'est pour la partie donc
civilisation qui encore une fois un des
enjeux absolument majeur face à la
montée de l'islamisme
un deuxième sujet que je voudrais très
brièvement très brièvement présenter
devant vous c'est évidemment leur
puissance vous savez aujourd'hui
l'europe est bien l'europe elle est
seule elle est seule face à deux
superpuissances qui sont la chine et les
états unis et l'europe doit être moins
naïve
l'europe doit moins subir elle doit
sortir de ses naïvetés pour protéger
davantage nos emplois nos entreprises et
donc nous allons mettre en oeuvre en
fait des garde-fous pour essayer de
protéger encore une fois un autre
ces emplois premièrement double
préférence européenne et française pour
donner la priorité à nos entreprises et
nos emplois
mettre fin aussi au dumping social et
vous l'avez vu avec les travailleurs
détachés il est absolument fondamental
que les travailleurs détachés payent
leur cotisation sociale dans le pays où
ils travaillent ça paraît une évidence
mais emmanuel macron ne le dit pas j'en
dirai pas plus et vous avez de toute
façon le projet extrêmement détaillées
mais je tiens à vous dire que nous
comptons sur votre mobilisation totale
il nous reste 70 jours parler autour de
vous vous avez vu et je tiens à
remercier devant vous tous la confiance
que laurent wauquiez m'a fait en me
désignant en tant que numéro 2 sur cette
liste j'ai une dette de reconnaissance
envers lui je lui si d'autant plus
reconnaissante que il a fait ce
rassemblement que nous attendions tous
et ce trio justement est l'incarnation
du renouvellement de la droite mais
aussi du rassemblement de toutes les
sensibilités de la droite et bravo à
laurent wauquiez d'avoir incarné ce
rassemblement je l'en remercie
bonjour passe la parole à arnaud mes
chers amis c'est extrêmement stimulant
et je dois dire émouvant vous voir et
vous sentir si nombreux aussi motivé
merci à tous pour votre confiance je
vais me faire haïr par les minuteurs et
les organisateurs mais je ne résiste pas
ici en auvergne rhône-alpes cher laurent
de vous raconter une anecdote que je
crois significative pour notre mouvement
nous étions hier avec françois-xavier
bellamy dans ta belle région cher
laurent nous étions en particulier dans
l'ain chez damien abad et à l'issue
d'une riche journée des changes comme
tous les jours depuis que nous sommes
entrés en campagne nous n'avons pas
résisté au plaisir d'aller supporter
oyonnax rugby écoutez bien ce que je
vais vous dire
[Musique]
écoutez bien ce que je vais vous dire
quand nous sommes entrés au stade avec
françois-xavier oyonnax était 3e 3e ça
vous dit peut-être quelque chose quand
le match s'est terminé
et quand françois xavier a quitté
oyonnax oyonnax était premier partout où
il passe partout où il passe
ça progresse
et ça gagne alors dans les piliers de
notre programme vous allez naturellement
retrouvé en très bonne place
l'europe qui protège alors vous allez me
dire l'europe qui protège on entend ça
partout c'est un slogan d'ailleurs que
tout le monde nous prend même le
président de la république qui s'en
étaient pas beaucoup préoccuper jusqu'à
présent même pas du tout s'est senti
obligé de parler de la protection dans
son dernier papier
sauf que l'europe qui protège il ya ceux
qui en parlent
il ya ceux qui de là des fonds parfois
il ya ceux qui seront en mesure de la
faire et qui ont déjà commencé à la
faire et nous je vous demande simplement
de regarder aussi notre liste quand sur
votre liste
dans les personnalités qui ont été cités
tout à l'heure vous avez bernard carayon
qui a travaillé sur l'intelligence
économique le patriotisme économique
quand vous avez philippe meunier notre
secrétaire nationale à la défense
quand vous avez bien brice hortefeux
ancien ministre de l'intérieur
quand vous avez frédéric péchenard
ancien directeur général de la police
nationale moi-même qui modestement
travaille depuis dix ans sur ces sujets
au parlement européen vous avez une
liste des personnalités crédibles pour
agir parce que c'est ça qu'on nous
demande on nous demande d'être utile on
nous demande d'être efficace
on nous demande pas seulement de passer
sur les plateaux télé en déclamant des
slogans et je peux vous dire que le
président macron voit une europe qui
protège aujourd'hui en créant toujours
plus de structures de technostructure d'
agence hors sol la sécurité mon cher
eric nous savons tous qu'elle commence
chez nous elle commence dans nos
quartiers dans nos villes dans notre
pays
le maillon fort de la sécurité c'est le
maillon nationale bien sûr qu'il faut la
coopération et nous nous sommes pour la
coopération
nous sommes pour une coopération
pragmatique efficace utile cette
coopération j'attire votre attention mes
chers amis il ya un groupe au parlement
européen qui depuis dix ans l'a défait
systématiquement la refuse
systématiquement c'est le groupe du
front national ce groupe qui se prétend
quand vous l'entendez le champion de
notre sécurité
ce groupe-là vote contre europol vos
votes contre front texte vote contre le
rétablissement des contrôles aux
frontières vote contre le pnr tous ces
instruments européens que nous ne
rejetons pas parce qu'ils sont européens
parce que nous sommes des pragmatiques
nous ne sommes pas des dogmatiques
quand l'europe peut faire plus pour
notre sécurité nous l'acceptons nous
l'encourageons et nous le mettons en
oeuvre et nous nous heurtons à des gens
qui est à gauche et encore plus à droite
que nous par togba tisme refusent ces
progrès pour nos concitoyens
voilà la réalité et voilà le travail que
nous devons mener et voilà les mensonges
que nous devons dénoncer
nous le croyons et nous sommes les seuls
à porter un message qui est un message
de la bonne articulation entre le niveau
national auquel nous n'abdiquerons
jamais et puis le niveau européen que
nous croyons utile quand il peut
apporter quelque chose de concret aux
français
cette double protection des frontières
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que bien
sûr nous devons adopter des règles
communes parce qu'il ne doit pas y avoir
de maillon faible en europe en
particulier pour gérer le droit d'asile
mais cette ces règles communes ne
doivent pas forcément s'incarner dans
une agence commune désincarné et qui ne
sait pas gérer les réalités nationales
donc nous nous voulons des règles
communes mais nous voulons aussi que in
fine et ce soient les états qui décident
de qui ils acceptent sur leur sol ou pas
et qui sommes-nous le double qui sommes
nous nous pour aller donner des leçon à
tous les pays européens
moi je ne me sens pas autorisé -
français et fier d'être français et
patriotes français
je ne le sens pas autorisées à aller
donner des leçons aux hongrois ou aux
polonais parce qu'il nous dise la
société multiculturelle que vous avez ne
fonctionne pas sommes nous si sûr que
nous avons réussi dans ce modèle pour
l'imposer aux autres
évidemment non évidemment non donc mes
chers amis la double protection c'est ça
c'est la bonne articulation entre le
national et l'européen nous voulons le
mettre en oeuvre
à tous les niveaux de notre sécurité
nous le voulons aussi je m'arrêterai la
chaire gens parce que je sais que
j'abuse un peu mais ce sont quand même
des sujets importants vous en
conviendrez
et nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
pendant et demi de un à deux mois et
demi par dont nous voulons aussi mettre
en place à l'échelle européenne un pacte
contre l'islamisme parce que ce
prosélytisme mortifère qui ronge qui
ronge dans nos quartiers dans tous les
quartiers et pas seulement en france
évidemment est de plus en plus de pays
européens sont en train de découvrir
cette réalité à laquelle ils n'étaient
pas confrontés ce prosélytisme mortifère
qui ronge les fondements de la laïcité
qui ronge les fondements de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes ma chère
lydia ce prosélytisme là nous ne pouvons
pas le tolérer
et il faudra bien que des règles
communes soit mise à l'échelle
européenne pour renvoyer les prêcheurs
de haine pour sanctionner ceux qui sont
financés par des nuisances étrangère et
pour enfin ensemble en europe s'attaquer
de front deux fronts à ce problème
j'irai pas plus loin aujourd'hui
merci de votre confiance l'europe qui
protège ses nous renvoient tous les
trois bravo à tous bon on avait une
synthèse du projet et si vous avez eu le
loisir juste en arrivant de lire le
livre est donc vous allez vous présenter
des cartons bleus passage au vote
est-ce que vous adoptez le projet
européen des républicains en alliance
avec les centristes
y'a pas un rouge vous restez tous dans
la salle
bravo merci bravo le rio bravo à
l'équipe bravo à vous tous